skill this is really good news is
learnable
when i started in the book business i
had bad taste
and editors didn't like what i thought
they would like and over time
my taste got better because i practiced
the work enough
amazon just broke me and i haven't read
my amazon reviews in seven or eight
years
and i don't miss it i could juggle for
you right now
just because why not but
no i'm terrible
today's episode of model the monsters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles
i've done over 3 800 split tests which
have led to results like taking this 5
year old video
that was getting 250 views a day and
just by changing the thumbnail it blew
up to 15
000 views per day you can get started on
tubebuddy for free
at tubebuddy.com evan ladies and
gentlemen we have a legend
in the house author of a new book called
the practice which is all about finding
your creativity unleashing your voice
and nothing counts until it ships
mr seth godin welcome aboard man thanks
evan great to talk to you
i don't know if you remember but back in
2010 i asked you who your favorite
famous entrepreneur was of all time and
you said duncan hines
duncan heinz and i got the card here i
am right behind me
do you really yes so i was making a line
of entrepreneur heroes trading cards
which was just trying to i love baseball
cards growing up and i thought hey
entrepreneurs are heroes and i asked you
who your favorite entrepreneurs this is
a decade ago
and you said duncan hines he built his
personal brand and his books around the
simple idea what's good for
my readers and and we use these cards to
raise
160 something thousand dollars for
entrepreneurs through kiva
doing micro loans to anyway
why duncan hines i i i mean people know
him as the
uh cake recipe guy but he was so much
more than that and you make me dive down
to a story what do you love about duncan
hines his autobiography is a hoot
and basically uh he was a real person he
was a good eater
and back in the day you couldn't go to a
strange town
and eat in a restaurant and not get sick
because locals didn't go to restaurants
they were
greasy spoons they were for people who
were from out of town he was a traveling
salesman
and he kept getting sick and then he
would keep notes as to which restaurants
he could visit that were safe and he was
also a little cheap so one year for
christmas instead of
actually giving everyone a present he
was in the printing business he printed
up his list
of safe restaurants and he gave it to
people and they
loved it and so year after year that
list got longer it was like there's a
god's restaurant guide
and then he started selling the
restaurants the right to put a sign
up front with his name on it saying
duncan says this place is okay
and then canned food came along and he
was really in the forest money turning
canned food into something safe
and then someone called them up and said
can i put your name on cake mix
and that company the last time i checked
sold for a billion dollars
because one person showed up and said
what do people want
when it comes to this thing so he didn't
hustle anybody
he didn't try to make himself famous he
simply said
there's a connection to be made here how
can i show up and narrate this
connection
in a way that people would be glad i was
here i love it
what do you think the biggest lesson
entrepreneurs creatives today could take
from duncan hines a story
well you know in the uh in my previous
book this is marketing i talk about the
smallest viable audience
and the problem with the business media
is
they lionize the home run hitters the
people who build
a trillion dollar company and i gotta
say i don't think tim cook has done
anything noteworthy except make
investors rich
i think what we really need to do as
entrepreneurs instead
is say who can i serve and instead of
saying how many people i can serve
we can say what's the smallest number of
people
that if i overwhelm them with the
generosity of what i'm making
they would tell the others and it would
be enough the smallest viable audience
so in duncan heinz's case it was a
hundred people
who wanted that list and then it was a
thousand restaurants that would benefit
from having the sign
and and then it gets big but it didn't
get big because duncan hines woke up one
day and said
i'm gonna make every person in america
buy a cake mix
instead he said what's this group of
people i could put myself on the hook
for
and deliver something of value i love it
so so the new book
talking about call the practice helping
people find their creative talent their
genius
that everybody has it it's not reserved
for the special few
i like to say in my videos that
everybody has michael jordan level
genius
at something and chances are it's not
what you went to school for what your
parents did for a living
but you have to find it otherwise you
live a life of mediocrity and chances
are
not being too happy uh i think a lot of
that's been addressed in the practice so
how does somebody
find their what i would call michael
jordan level genius
in your words well i love that using
michael jordan as an example because i
often talk about interesting talent and
skill
and i'll say basketball players have to
have
talent because i will never be able to
dunk in basketball i was not born
with the dna that will make me tall
enough to do that
however you are correct there are plenty
of tall people who are not michael
jordan
michael jordan isn't michael jordan
because of talent he's that because of
skill
and skill this is really good news is
learnable
and if it's learnable what i have to ask
somebody is have
even once you said something that
someone else wanted to hear even once
done something remarkable original
creative generous if you've done it once
then it's not a talent then it's
available to you and the way you get
to do it again is by practicing your
skill
getting better at your skill even if it
doesn't work right away especially if it
doesn't work right away
so is it lack of belief people just
don't think they have
michael jordan level genius at something
well you know imposter syndrome is real
imposter syndrome is an epidemic that
says i feel like a fraud
how dare i show up in this social media
or start a podcast or be wherever
who am i to do this and people say how
do i get rid of imposter syndrome
and what i say to them is well the
reason you have imposter syndrome is
that you're an imposter
and you can't make it go away because
we're all imposters if you're leading
well then you're trying to do something
that's never been done before that's why
we call it leadership
and we have to embrace that we can
embrace it
by saying yeah of course i feel this way
it means i'm on to something
and that idea that i'm on to something i
can
dance with it is a little bit like
saying
i know i'm running the marathon because
my legs are tired if my legs weren't
tired something would be wrong
that's a feature it's not a bug so even
getting
to the place of imposter syndrome i
would presuppose they're
they've created something they're
they've already made something and now
they feel like an impossible talking
about it
what about even just the belief that you
can be creative
a lot of people never even get impostor
syndrome at least in my head because
they don't even think they
they have the creative gene inside them
like how do you overcome that belief
system with people
yeah well the indoctrination runs deep
it runs deep around racial injustice it
runs deep around economic separation
it's been something that's been talked
to us from an early age so i'll
give a talk back in the day when people
came together for talks
and there's a hundred people there a
thousand people there you'll say any
questions
and no one will raise their hand and
then when the talk is over people run up
to
ask their secret question well why
couldn't they ask their question in
front of everyone else
because they were taught not to because
it might be stupid it might waste
someone's time it might not be a
contribution
and so it runs really deep inside us to
say i don't have any good ideas
well no what you're really saying is i'm
afraid of my bad ideas
i am so afraid of my bad ideas i'm not
willing to say them even though
a good idea might slip in
and so what's the recipe to overcome
that
well if it doesn't ship it doesn't count
and the only way you get better at
anything is by shipping the work
and to ship the work we need two things
one we need to do it from a place of
generosity
you can't run around hustling people and
hope that it'll work
because no one wants to be hustled no
one wakes up in the morning saying i
hope someone will come hustle me
and then the second thing which is
related is if you're doing it in the
right spirit
you need to be completely disconnected
from the outcome
that it is about throwing not catching
that it is about
putting your best work into the world
regardless of whether it works or not
and then if it doesn't work learning
from it so you can do it again
but actually what people say to
themselves is well i'll pitch
but if it's not a no-hitter i'm never
going to pitch again and that just
doesn't work
and they want to know hitter on their
first game yeah exactly
people asking about quality versus
quantity and i i usually tell them well
the quantity leads to the quality like
it's not
either or like the more you do the
better you get at the thing you're
trying to learn and to expect to suck
at the beginning of anything write in
the book right in the blog making
youtube videos
is that in alignment with how you're
thinking yeah i mean walking talking
riding a bicycle if you can ride a
bicycle i would say
do you ride it better than you did your
first day
right at what point is it appropriate
for someone to say i will never be able
to ride a bicycle and give up
if you have you know fairly standard
motor skills the answer is never it is
never okay to say that
but some people do because they couldn't
ride a bike perfectly the first day
i'm not sure there's a difference
between riding a bike and writing world
level
copy or leading a non-profit
or writing a business plan that's
actually going to work
and speaking of business plans having
seen the business plans for
organizations like yahoo and google i
can tell you
there's nothing in common between their
business plan and what they actually
built
because the bus that's why no one
publishes their business plan because
they look like idiots
it's just this was enough to get us
started it's not this is the roadmap
and so is it just a matter of like you
do with your blog if i'm going to write
something every single day and put it up
i love the idea of streaks so i'm 7
500 blog posts in a row and there will
be a blog post tomorrow
and it won't come out because it's
perfect it will come out because it's
tomorrow
i only decided once to write a blog post
every day
and then i don't have to decide anymore
the decision has been made
now it's just go ahead and do it the
same way you decided
a long time ago to brush your teeth
every day you don't have to have a
meeting with yourself about whether i
should brush my teeth or not today
you just brush your teeth one of the
things i've
admired the most about you is that
consistency of
writing the blog post and creating the
books and there's always something new
coming out
i've tried to do it with my youtube
channel six thousand plus videos on the
channel now wow
yeah over 10 11 years 2019 was my first
video upload
um one of the things that really
terrified me was being the aging rock
star
of having some big hit in when you're 20
or 30
and then you just keep repeating the
same hit every time you're going on tour
singing the same songs and not creating
anything new and what i love
about what you're doing is always
something new you might reference an old
book or no blog post but but
it's like you're creating something new
right now and and tomorrow there's
something new coming out as well
so for the people who may feel like well
i had some hit
that worked but then now nothing else
seems to match up so i'm
i guess i just keep repeating that same
record and that's basically the death of
creativity
what what would you what would you tell
them counsel them advise them to do
well you know that it's fun to dissect
that so let's
talk first about hits i have never had a
blog post that won the internet
right i've never had a blog post that
everyone read i'm thrilled by that
because that sort of hit where you when
you fall off the power law curve
really messes with your head because
then you try
to recreate it right so if you think
about joni mitchell or ricky lee jones
they it took them many records to get
over the fact
that they had had a monster hit because
they were trying
to reproduce something they had never
set out to do in the first place
which was the the market wanted them
to play covers of their selves and they
decided they wanted to go down a
different path
but on the other hand genre matters and
when we show up in the world with our
work our audience wants it to remind
them
of us that we are always playing covers
of ourself
and you know in dylan's case you can't
even recognize
the old songs when he sings them today
because he intentionally mumbles them
but if you buy something from nike
you don't want to buy a candy bar from
them
because it doesn't remind you of nike
and
when you go and watch you know
lin-manuel miranda's new play you want
it to at some level remind you of
hamilton
because genre matters and coming up with
something that rhymes with itself
is a discipline that gives us boundaries
to be creative
when you talk about recognizing the
throw and not the catch it's not about
the results
are you then just tying your self-esteem
to the effort you're putting in like did
i show up today and give my best
is that how you're doing it internally i
i don't think so so
juggling right if you want to learn how
to juggle
what most people do is they focus on
catching because it's when you drop the
ball that it's so embarrassing
when you watch a juggler and they drop
the ball you go oh
but if you try to catch it you're gonna
lunge
and lunging destroys everything there is
about juggling
you cannot lunge and continue to jungle
juggle
and so everybody who knows how to juggle
focuses on throwing
they are intending to end up being a
good juggler but they
understand throwing is the secret to the
whole thing
because if you get good at throwing the
catching takes care of itself
and what i'm trying to say by
disassociating myself from the outcome
is this
if i try to imagine what the critic from
publishers weekly wants
and imagine what this person wants and
and i'm willing
that person to like what i wrote all the
juice will come out of the work
all come out of the work all of the good
stuff will be eliminated because i will
be reverse engineering the work
instead i focus on throwing is that a
good throw
is that a good throw is that a good
throw and if you get good at throwing
the catching will take care of itself
and so
just to pick an example publishers
weekly has hated
every book i have ever done that has
succeeded
now it's interesting to note their only
job in their reviews is to tell book
sellers what books are going to succeed
so clearly they are bad at their job but
if i was worried
about that negative feedback and i was
reverse engineering for it
i never would have written the books i
wrote and so when they say we don't like
this book so much i'm thrilled
because it means that one of the things
i'm looking for in the marketplace
actually happened which is i wrote a
book that didn't pander
to publishers weekly how good is your
juggling
my juggling is by most standards very
weak
um but i'm one of the best juggling
teachers you will ever meet i have
taught
more than a thousand people had a juggle
wow all right
cool and i do it by teaching we spend
the first half hour we don't catch one
ball
and it's very frustrating particularly
for 10 year olds to do that because
they're so
it's it will make you cry to watch 10
year olds become
so obsessed with catching the ball
and first we have to strip that away and
then
we get to the next level but one of my
projects for
2020 is to actually get better at
juggling
all right like i could juggle for you
right now just because
why not but no i'm terrible
i'm just good at teaching so
so breaking down that analogy with
publisher weekly you're not trying to
get them to
say this is you know the practice is the
greatest book of all time otherwise
you've read a different book
you're showing up every day in service
to your audience to say hey how can i
make something that people would
like but it's still a distant you know
to get that reaction back from people
still
you know months or a year year away what
are you telling yourself on a daily
basis to say
am i proud of myself for showing up is
it that you block off
x hours a day and like i sat there and i
tried writing is it like the effort of
showing up
daily that then you're that's how you
pat yourself on the back and say i'm
proud of myself what i did today
no different people so i i was friends
with isaac asimov
years ago i did a project with him he
wrote uh
400 books he invented robots as we know
them if you've ever seen a robot in a
movie
that was isaac and i said isaac how do
you publish 400 books
and he said well i get up and i sit at
this manual typewriter
6 30 in the morning and i type till noon
every day
and it doesn't matter if you type good
stuff or bad stuff sooner or later good
stuff would slip through
so that was his approach which was a
volume based approach that
eliminated the thing that was holding
him back
in my case what i am looking for is
a a glimpse of something that scares me
a glimpse of something where i notice
something or
make a connection and then i say that'll
never work
no one will get the joke that's going to
be a dead end
but something about it has a spark to it
and then the second half which is almost
never happens on the same day as the
first half
is did i do service to that
notion by showing up and showing up and
showing up
until it was polished enough to share
and those are both halves of my work
and i can't make either one of them
happen on demand
and so you schedule it in to show up and
do the work
so i try to strip away i don't go to
meetings
i don't watch television um and
i don't use social media so if i'm bored
enough
i will find myself doing one of those
two things to entertain myself
got it as you're talking uh the the word
you know self-esteem just keeps popping
into my head but people tie their
self-esteem
to getting the positive reviews or to
get in the instagram likes or to get
so it's replacing what we tie our
self-esteem to instead of
the likes and the shares and the number
one seller but then to what
to to to service to showing up every day
to doing the difficult thing that you
didn't think you could do
like what are we switching what we tie
our self-esteem to yeah
yeah so these are great questions evan
okay let's think about what it means to
have good taste
because it's something that people talk
about all the time but what does it
actually mean
and i have a proposed definition which
is good taste
is knowing what your customers want
before they do
because copying isn't good taste
and furnishing your house to look
exactly like a picture of martha stewart
is in good taste that's just copying
right
but if you're able to go just a little
bit ahead so that when the people you
seek to be aligned with
look at it and say wow you have good
taste what they mean is
you're a little bit ahead of where i am
and that is what i am keeping track of
not
that they told me i have good taste but
that i told myself that it is quite
likely
that when someone sees this thing i
polished it is just far enough ahead
of the way they see the world that it
will turn on a light for them
and if it doesn't then i say oh
well that didn't work what can i throw
next
but i have enough genre experience to
know
when it looks like it might work and
that
came the hard way when i started in the
book business i had bad taste
and editors didn't like what i thought
they would like and they didn't
embrace what i thought they would
embrace and over time my taste got
better
because i practiced the work enough and
so is that self-reminder and intentional
practice
because when you're doing a blog post
you get feedback right away
but when you're writing a book it's
going to take you a long time so i'm
just wondering for people who are
doing your creative work that might and
and i know your your version of writer's
block isn't just for writing it's any
creative endeavor
so for anybody who's taking on a big
project where they may not be getting
market feedback for 3 6 12 18 months
is that in a daily practice to say what
i made today i think
is in good taste and will serve like is
that an intentional practice at the end
of the day
to remind yourself of what you're doing
and the why it's a big part of it also i
am completely divorced from market
feedback
i don't keep track of my traffic on my
blog i have no idea how many books i'm
selling
i want to hear two months six months
12 months later this thing i read made a
difference
in the way i worked my life to hear you
say 11 years later that me talking about
duncan hines contributed to something at
kiva
that's the work for me not
that someone uh put a little plus sign
or that some social media product
came along and said i did a good job i
used to be
really focused on that and then
amazon just broke me and i haven't read
my amazon reviews in seven or eight
years
and i don't miss them it's just all an
amazon review is
or a youtube comment is somebody
telling you about them not telling you
about you
if someone posts in your youtube
comments that they don't like you and
your work
all they're saying is i'm not the kind
of person that likes work like this
okay thank you for telling us about you
but you're not going to change
us because we make work like this
and when you say it broke you what does
that mean that you didn't you couldn't
handle the the negativity coming in or
what does that mean anonymous negative
feedback is a problem for me because i
want to go to
that person and explain myself okay i
want to say but wait wait didn't you see
what it said three pages before that
right and it has never worked
when they're not anonymous and it
doesn't make me happy
even if you get a glimmer of oh yeah
it's just a trap and so this idea that
we're going to
give up our state of mind and our
well-being
because the stranger that we made a
guess about
we guessed wrong it just it fraught for
me i think it's way better
to create our own standards figure out
how much enough
is and once you can get enough then get
back to work
as opposed to trying to get everything
let me throw something out and see if
you catch it
um in terms of responding to comments
because
we've made the opposite where we respond
to every single comment in every single
video
um one
to remove this thing you just have
empathy like if somebody's coming and
the height of their day is leaving some
negative comment like they hate their
life right
but in responding our philosophy is not
to try to change that person although it
does happen like
the amount of people come back the next
day to say hey i'm really sorry i was in
a really
crappy mood yesterday and all that right
but it's more for
educating the people who are watching it
because that becomes more content how
you handle one comment
in a negative way and give them love
it's everybody else who's watching and
even if you never ship the person who
left the comment yeah no i applaud you
for doing that okay you have
a much more generous streak when it
comes to this than i do i don't have the
resources to do that
appropriately and i discovered first
when i had comments on my blog
i was writing in a different way
anticipating the comments
instead of saying something in one
sentence i would say in four
just so no one would misinterpret the
first sentence
and i realized i was either going to
have a lousy blog with comments
or the blog i wanted without comments
which one
and i picked the blog with no comments
and i get that
there is a huge value to be had in the
calm
centered way that you are seeing people
and reacting and responding not reacting
responding to them
it's just not work i can do but i
totally get it if that's working for you
or for anyone else
i think it's great cool and i think
that's also maybe part of the the
message in the practice is
how you show up and how your creative is
going to be different compared to
somebody else you can you can model but
not copy to find out
how you best show up awesome so the book
is called the practice uh we're going to
link it up down the description below if
you want to go check it out
i mean we've talked around it just
quickly kind of last message from my
audience to
to dive into it what's the what's the
theme and why is it so important for
entrepreneurs to pick it up
what does an entrepreneur do right an
entrepreneur
builds something bigger than herself an
entrepreneur shows up to solve
an interesting problem it is not
freelancing
it is not just a small business it is
about making significant change in the
world
that involves creativity doing something
that might not work
showing up and saying here i made this
putting yourself
on the hook if you want to do all those
things
yes you need to know how to use google
sheets yes you probably need to know how
to do an elevator pitch
but what you really need is the
narrative
of showing up to do creative work
and that is something we haven't talked
about a lot and i wanted to outline for
people
how it can become your practice because
this time it might not work and the next
time it might not work
but if it becomes your practice you'll
be able to make things better
and that's my mission i love it the book
is called the practice we've linked it
up in the description go
check it out seth godin thank you for
your time man appreciate you
what a pleasure thank you go make a
ruckus if you want to change your life
for the next 30 days for free check the
link right here below me
or if you want to see the top 10 i did
on seth godin check the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there